after bringing baby Archie to a
high-profile meeting in South Africa the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex have gone
their separate ways for this trip only
carries in Botswana seeing conservation
and local wildlife preservation projects
Megan on the other hand is remaining in
Cape Town hosting local women's groups
Deborah patches in Cape Town South
Africa
Deborah looks like a full agenda for
both Royals today Megan is going solo
for the next few days hosting a number
of private engagements this morning it
was a breakfast with women in public
service like local politicians and
community activists while Prince Harry
turns neighboring Botswana Prince Harry
is in Botswana to see firsthand how
there are tackling wildlife conservation
and alluded to the fact that he wasn't
the only person using some star power to
highlight global environmental issues
last week the world's children are
striking in which we are losing the Duke
also joins schoolchildren planting trees
and the Chobe Forest Reserve Harry then
met with a youth group part of his
centre ballet project centre ballet
which means forget-me-nots is one of
Harry's deepest passions co-founded by
him in 2006 it improves the lives of
those living with hiv/aids and continues
the legacy of Princess Diana's fight to
destigmatize the virus
he spoke movingly about how Botswana
helped him in the tough months after her
death and the lifelong bond it created
97-98 story off my mum died so it was a
nice place to get away from it all but
now I feel deeply connected to this
place and Africa
and that connection is likely to be even
more firmly cemented with Prince Ari in
Angola tomorrow where he will literally
retrace his mother's footsteps across an
Angolan land minefield one of the most
iconic images of Diana's short life
Anthony certainly was Debora patta in
South Africa thank you interesting the
family history there it means so much to
him his love for Africa is very deep